la face cachée des énergies vertes un
documentaire signé jean louis pérez et
guillaume pitron qui bouscule pas mal
les esprits sur ce que le grand public
croit savoir des énergies vertes avec
nous pour en parler ronan dantec
bienvenus vous êtes sénateur écologiste
de la loire atlantique membre du groupe
d'études énergie au sénat vous êtes vice
président de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable avec nous
également marc four cave bienvenus
professeur au collège de france membre
de l'académie des sciences président du
comité de prospective en énergie et
auteur de ce livre halte au
catastrophisme les vérités de la
transition énergétique avec nos
également bettina laville bienvenue si
vous êtes présidente cofondatrice du
comité 21 ans d'un réseau d'acteurs
engagés dans le développement durable et
directrice de la rédaction de la revue
vraiment durable avec nous également
mais à distance diego l'endive art
bienvenue vous êtes enseignant chercheur
en économie et une manie t numerica le
sc clairement auteurs de ce livre
héritage et fermeture une écologie du
démantèlement vous êtes également co
auteur d'une tribune dans le monde
intitulée crise climatique nous devons
apprendre à d innover on va parler tout
ça je le disais en introduction
quand on est peu connaisseur du sujet
ronan dantec
on est un peu abasourdi par le tableau
dressé dans ce documentaire sur les
énergies vertes y aurait rien propre
dans ces énergies dites propres moi ce
documentaire est précieux il faut
l'utiliser dans toutes les écoles de
journalisme
parce que c'est objectivement un très
mauvais documentaire c'est en fait du
grand n'importe quoi pour faire court
c'est à dire pourquoi on ne les
hiérarchise pas les enjeux c'est à dire
que on ne les rares chispa entre les
impacts réels négatifs d'une activités
extractives et le dérèglement climatique
de changements climatiques menacent
l'avenir même de nos sociétés pour pas
dire arche isation il apparaît
clairement aussi que dans la manière
d'équilibrer les paroles dans le
documentaire ça n'y est pas et puis
alors il ya des confusions mais vraiment
de deux niveaux je dirais collège par
exemple en confondant ski et les
émissions de co2 et la pollution
atmosphérique les deux selles sont des
choses assez différentes y compris des
fois pour lutter contre un peu sur une
série qu'en nommant des émissions de co2
donc qu'on avoir des confusions de ce
niveau qui a quand même quand on bosse
un sujet un niveau un peu de base ça dit
que ce documentaire en fait est un peu
une farce mais qui a eu un impact et
c'est un peu le problème parce qu'on est
aussi dans une société qui qui sort la
rationalité qui sort du scientifique
vous êtes d'accord marque fondecave
c'est un documentaire très orienté qui
du coup ne dit pas la vérité parce que
quand on est grand public on a besoin
d'apprendre vraiment des choses sur des
énergies vertes qui ne le serait pas je
serai pas aussi critique que monsieur
dantec mais je voudrais dire la chose
suivante alors c'est sans doute parce
que je suis danse danse sur ces
questions là depuis très très longtemps
c'est que sur le fond je n'ai pas appris
grand chose moi même pourquoi parce que
l'idée que toute activité
conduit à des pollutions à des déchets
c'est quelque chose que j'ai appris tout
petit quand on fait de la physique il ya
un certain nombre de principes de la
thermodynamique qui nous indique que
tout système thermodynamique évolué avec
plus de désordre c'est c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'augmentation de l'entropie
donc c'est assez classique donc je ne
suis pas surpris enfin je dirais l'idée
qui consiste à dire aux gens qu'il n'y a
aucun système miracle et que tout
système conduit à des pollutions
ça c'était pas nouveau ce qui est quand
même intéressant dans ce dans ce
documentaire
alors la deuxième chose c'est que et là
je suis assez d'accord c'était qu'à
partir du moment où on a compris que
au fond tout système toute technologie
aura des impacts négatifs ça peut être
la pollution le co2 ça peu différentes
choses
évidemment on peut selon son son île sa
propre idéologie ou ses propres idées
pointé du doigt exclusivement
exclusivement sur une en faisant croire
qu'il n'y avait que celle là qui
seraient toxiques ou
très mauvaise pour l'environnement
moi qui suit mais peut-être
contrairement à vous pour le maintien du
nucléaire pendant un certain temps
justement pour les raisons climatiques
et justement par rapport à cette
question de la priorité du co2 est
évidemment je sais très bien les impacts
négatifs du nucléaire mais et donc je ne
vais pas m'amuser comme le fait ce
documentaire de dire donner l'impression
qu'il ya que là que ça se passait dans
les énergies localisées sur un poids ne
veut pas dire que c'est faux menant
d'entrée on se dit c'est faux et c'est
faux ou pas
bien c'est bien sûr que non c'est pas
faux je veux dire le fait que les
batteries électriques ont besoin de
grafite et qu'on va les extraire je veux
dire c'est ses photos sur les mines de
grafite en chine
c'est pas des fêtes news c'est normal
c'est 50 de faits sont vrais mais que le
documentaire n'est pas faux
le narratif qui est fait à partir
d'éléments vrai parce que moi le premier
je suis soucieux de l'impact des
activités extractives ce soit des terres
rares du pétrole ou autre chose donc
donc mais à partir d'un certain nombre
d'éléments qui peuvent être vraies on a
un narratif qui lui est du grand
n'importe quoi bein bettina laville on
va poursuivre quand même ce tour de
table avec vous ces énergies politel
autant que les autres oui non la réponse
est oui mais autrement moi je trouve que
là où prenant la raison c'est que il
faut aussi d'ailleurs vous venez de le
dire c'est que le documentaire en fait
n'explique pas que la société actuelle
et la transition est extrêmement
complexe il ya une thèse une thèse
effectivement de dire les énergies vers
pollue autant que l'énergie entre
guillemets classique alors probablement
c'est pas vrai parce que au niveau et
rothschild option hiérarchise pour
l'instant ce qui pollue ce n'est pas ce
que c'est de plus important c'est le
charbon le sait très bien et c'est quand
même la priorité qu'on doit totalement
visé d'élimination du charbon dieu merci
ça commence et deuxièmement il dit de
façon un peu naïve je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous toute activité
humaine et par exemple quelqu'un dans le
documentaire part de l'extractivisme bon
et bien a effectivement une face cachée
là où je trouve que documentaire n'est
pas très honnête
c'est que en fait qu'il parle de
substitution à notre modèle aujourd'hui
énergétique polluantes et à la fin il
n'y a aucune solution en fait tout est
pareil à aucune solution et ça rejoint
en fait le débat sur l'innovation verte
qui aujourd'hui est mise en question et
c'est donc ça c'est pas du tout adapté
la seconde chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que il pose là où je trouve
intéressant c'est qu'il fait un peu le
tour des pays et il montre bien à quel
point des pays s'engouffre vert je
dirais une mono extraction par exemple
la bolivie existant parce que ça va les
sauver sur le plan économique et là
effectivement c'est complètement renoncé
à
point de vue mondial qu'on doit avoir et
au point de vue qui consiste à dire on
doit tous s'y mettre pour ne pas tomber
dans des excès qui effectivement vont
appauvrir les pays pauvres et les rendre
dépendants d'une autre manière et on y
viendra cette question sociale zygoland
ivars comment l'avez-vous vu de votre
côté ce documentaire quand on en sort on
en droit de se poser la question de
savoir si on a eu tort de tout miser sur
ces énergies renouvelables avec tout ce
qu'elles ont comme défaut que l'on vient
d'évoquer ici
oui je pense que ce documentaire a le
mérite au moins deux un petit peu mettre
en pause cette sorte de cour chaleyssin
échalotes sur sur les questions de
l'innovation verte technologique verte
et c est en fait rend visible des
entités des communautés des personnes
des acteurs qui sont souvent
complètement un visibiliser part
justement cette euphorie innovante qui
quittent ans a dominé les débats et je
pense que ce qui est intéressant aussi
malgré effectivement les approximations
mais bon c'est un documentaire c'est pas
c'est pas un article de recherche
évaluées par des pairs on peut pas
demander à des journalistes n'ont plus
le même type de rendu
etc mais en tout cas ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça rend les
problèmes visible et sarrant des
communautés qui est par exemple je viens
de bolivie la question du lithium elle
est étroitement lié à un extractives
isme qui justement pose des questions
essentielles est ce qu'on peut pour la
bolivie par exemple est ce qu'on
continue à hua hin exploiter le lithium
pour des raisons de ressources
financières stratégiques pour le pays ou
est-ce qu'on renonce y compris du pays
c'est à dire que la bolivie se pose
aussi cette question là c'est pas juste
le marché qui qui qui va va statuer et
ça je trouve ça assez intéressant de
rendre en fait un petit peu visibles ces
entités effacés en en teck et marc 24 et
moi je suis d'accord sur ce point
simplement on peut faire le même
documentaire même empire en plus
terrifiant sur les sables bitumineux de
l'alaska sur la bauxite en afrique sur
le coltan pour nos téléphones portables
en rdc donc on a un vrai problème
effectivement sur l'extraction des
matières premières
oui mais le premier par exemple le
premier problème sur l'excès sur les
matières sur l'extradition excuses mardi
n'a jamais dit en même temps que les
sables bitumeux 2 c'était les énergies
vertes non mais c'est pour dire s'est il
n'y a pas un produit si importante et je
crois qu'on était on est tous d'accord
on va pouvoir dans ces vies dans des
bars on est tous d'accord entre nous
pour dire qu'on a un problème sur
l'extraction des matières premières
rappelez quand même que la première
conséquence de l'extraction du pétrole
c'est des guerres un peu partout avec ça
ça fait beaucoup plus de dégâts encore
que l'impact de ce qu'on a vu la même si
ça ne t'a pas que tu es juste et du coup
je pense que les vraies questions et du
coup ce documentaire provoque peut nous
aider là dessus c'est il ya deux
questions la première alors soit on peut
remettre en cause toute extraction mais
on a un besoin majeur quand même de
sortir des émissions énergétiques
thermique et c'est la priorité ça c'est
la priorité sinon sinon nos sociétés
septfonds charbon pétrole font sortir à
partir de là la seule manière de faire
fonctionner nos machines c'est
l'électricité est effectivement derrière
l'électricité en production possible
sans co2 il y a massivement les énergies
renouvelables et un peu en termes de
pourcentage le nucléaire après ya le
débat énergies renouvelables nucléaire
mais c'est un débat qui vient plus tard
donc moi je pense qu'à partir de là une
fois qu'on a dit clairement on n'a pas
le choix soit on passe à une société a2c
à de l'électricité produite de manière
non et missiles de co2 parce que sinon
tout s'effondre une fois que l'on avait
dit ça alors on regarde les problèmes
posés et on a des problèmes sur
l'extraction et du coup de là dessus je
pense qu à deux questions vraiment
importante que le documentaire
finalement puisqu'il est parti un peu à
charles malheureusement
n'explore pas trop
c'est d'abord le prix des matières
premières c'est à dire que si un tel
impact environnemental c'est parce que
ces extractions ne sont pas accompagnés
en termes de compensations en termes de
mesures environnementales parce que
c'est pas cher c'est pas cher ce qui
remet en cause le recyclage aussi
pourquoi on recycle pas les terres rares
c'est que finalement elles sont pas si
cher sur le marché mondial tant qu'a
toujours cette question qui est assez
postcoloniale du prix des matières
premières petit 1 et 2 il ya
effectivement une grande question
géopolitique acquis un peu dans le
documentaire mais qui là aussi est
totalement simplifiée parce que la chine
n'a pas le monopole et en plus les
terres rares sont pas si rares et on met
les miens mais les chinois les produits
ça moins cher c'est plus une question de
prix que de raréfaction de la ressource
et donc qu'on a une question vraiment
géopolitique de se dire c'est quoi un
monde où demain ses ressources
nécessaires sont extraites de manière
correcte et surtout profite au pays et
pas uniquement à nos industries je vous
donne la parole dans un instant marque
fondecave on va revoir un extrait
ensemble de ce documentaire parce que
cette extraction métaux dont dépendent
les énergies vertes on l'a vu ne se fait
pas sans casse humaine et sociale ça a
été très frappant dans ce film l'un des
intervenants parlent même de population
sacrifier pour les pays riches on
regarde ensemble et on en parle après
sont des zones sacrifices elles
sacrifient leur territoire leur
géographie la santé de leurs populations
et tous ces sacrifices ce fonds au
bénéfice d'autres zones qui en profite
ces zones là elles doivent s'offrir le
luxe de promouvoir les énergies propres
énergie scène les énergies renouvelables
les énergies vertes mais il faut bien
que quelqu'un paie le prix
c'est très fort ce qu'il dit marc
fondecave c'est évident que cette
affirmation est vraie en effet
nous nous délocalisons nos pollutions ou
un certain nombre de l'activité et donc
ça pose la question mais alors qui est
assez général qui m'intéresse aussi
c'est alors on peut l'appeler
relocalisation politique industrielle
mai mais en matière période d'extraction
ou ou de recyclage récupération
effectivement on a à relocaliser à
recentrer à renationaliser un certain
nombre d'activités et pour cela il faut
une politique industrielle par un psy
vous une faveur si vous ne fabrique pas
évidemment vous n'avez aucune chute de
fabrication que vous pouvez récupérer
voyez tout ça s'enclenche donc moi ce
que je veux juste pour continuer et
participer à ce débat qui a été lancée
il ya une telle pression pour nous faire
croire que ça y'est toutes les solutions
sont là et qu'il n'ya plus qu'à se
débarrasser des fossiles et du nucléaire
et d'avoir 100% d'énergies renouvelables
que les gens le croient alors ça
évidemment d'abord ça sera difficilement
possible et par ailleurs ça ne se fera
pas en quelques jours dans quelques
années dans un choix donc ça si énergies
vertes énergie près bien sûr et donc ça
pousse ça pousse tout le monde à croire
ça et en mettant de côté les impacts
dont on parle là dans ce documentaire
est qu'il faut que les gens sachent même
si à nouveau il faut être honnête et
dire qu'il n'ya pas claque ça se passe
comme ça et ça pousse en effet la
bolivie même si aujourd'hui c'est vrai
ils commencent à se poser la question de
leur propre environnement mais si yvon
la bolivie si les chinois vont dans le
graphite c'est parce qu'il ya un marché
colossal et que nous nous leur demandons
ça nous n'avons pas de lithium n'ont pas
de graphite et c'est enfin on s'est créé
des nouvelles dépendances bah on s'est
créé de nouvelles dépendances et puis et
puis surtout on a décidé qu'on avait la
solution et que c'était 100% de déo lien
batterie et de et
de solaire dont donc personne a décidé
que c'était simple pour ça si vous
regardez un scénario de l'ademe de rte
la suite de l'histoire je suis d'accord
la suite de l'histoire c'est d'arriver à
100 % mais ça veut dire aussi des sauts
technologiques que le documentaire élude
il ya juste une petite intervention de
la
parole
pour un scientifique par exemple cet
enjeu au delà de tout ce qu'on a entendu
cet enjeux du recyclage de la
récupération c'est quelque chose d'assez
fantastique pour un scientifique c est
ce qu'on va pouvoir
mobiliser des ingénieurs des chercheurs
et c'est à se poser la question 2 1 en
effet peut-être c'est celle à des
innovations jeu on va avoir
l'explication mais c'est cessé d'innover
en tenant compte de la possibilité de la
facilitation à récupérer et à recycler
et puis il ya toutes les technologies de
recyclage et de récupération qui aussi
ne sont pas suffisamment efficaces donc
donc il ya aussi en termes d'innovation
des choses à développer pour
aussi traiter la question de la
récupération du recyclage moi j'ai
travaillé un peu dans ce domaine et je
peux vous dire j'ai un brevet sur la
récupération du lithium par exemple mais
on a été confronté en 2021 enfin c'était
un peu avant à des problèmes de type
scientifiques fondamentaux pour séparer
des éléments séparés des métaux de
solvants on sait pas faire aujourd'hui
donc ça nous prendra un certain nombre
de temps mais si si on pense que tout
est résolu alors à ce moment-là on à
cette difficulté qu'on veut sauf dans le
temps on a manqué 10 goals en diva et
non ça c'est bon
je voudrais juste simplement à vous dire
là dessus c'est à dire que effectivement
l'appel à l'innovation technologique est
un peu un peu tout azimut c'est à dire
qu'on va effectivement soit à voir par
exemple la géo ingénierie qui vous dit
il faut manipuler le système terre et le
climat avec la nouvelle prise ingénieux
rial du monde et que c'est ça qui va
permettre de piloter les fameux deux
degrés peut-être même compenser un peu
plus et cetera ou sinon l'innovation on
va dire écologiser qui justement cherche
à verdir toutes nos technologies en fait
derrière tout ça il ya un implicite qui
est très fort qui est celui de
considérer que notre modèle de
développement économique social et
absolument sacré et qu' il faut renoncer
a absolument rien c'est à dire qu'il
faut toucher c'est juste un problème de
moyens techniques qui qui font que ce
modèle il est un petit peu sale compte
il se réalise mais que si on règle cette
problématique du propre de rendre notre
modèle propre on aura tout résolu le
problème c'est que nous dans notre
enquête on voit bien que dans des
dossiers très concret c'est-à-dire par
exemple la transition énergétique des
bâtiments sportifs dans des métropoles
ou d eau des villes la transition en
termes de mobilité etc en fait on arrive
à des plafonds des as en tête qui sont
toujours compliquées c'est à dire qu'on
peut optimiser tout ce que l'on veut si
on n'a pas résolu le problème des
échelles d échelle de production et de
consommation on va on va jamais je pense
arriver à résoudre l'équation donc en
fait il ya je pense qu'il ya trois
paradigmes le premier parking c'est
celui d'innovation intensive
technologique ouverte peu importe le
deuxième paradigme c'est de recourir des
mécanismes de compensation donc ça c'est
le ccc dérégulation marchande des
incitations et ses non dits que ces deux
paradigmes sont épuisés qui va falloir
passer maintenant faut mettre les pieds
dans le plat et dire il va falloir
inventer une
nouvelle gestion est nouvelle à un
nouvel art de l'arbitrage démocratique
pour savoir ce à quoi nous tenons
qu'est-ce qui est essentielle quels sont
les privilèges écologique qu'il faut
rendre caduque et qui est dont il faut
se débarrasser et ensuite deuxièmement
étant donné qu'on va décider de
certaines choses dont on va ce débat on
va se séparer cette séparation se pare
de la séparation c'est un général et
l'ingénierie de la séparation il va
falloir aussi l'inventer parce que notre
modernité nos pays occidentaux ça fait
très longtemps qu'elles ont appris à
ouvrir des choses à multiplier des
innovations des projets etc et
aujourd'hui va falloir maintenant
apprendre à fermer et ça techniquement
le capitalisme ne sait pas le faire
alors que pourtant il y à des métiers
des compétences des gens qui en fait
gère au quotidien tous les on va dire
les cadavres de deux du capitalisme et
qui en fait n'est toi nettoie notre
système s'occupe de la déposition des
commissions nos applications dans les
organisations etc etc et ça c'est une
affaire qui est qui ne peut pas être
résolu d'un point de vue purement
scientifique et technique donc il faut
pas juste isoler le débat est laissée
comme pour eux pourquoi quand il quand
il est le nouveau rapport du giec on
voulait une réponse il faut que le giec
nous disent quoi faire mais logique n'a
pas cette fonction et bruno latour lundi
très bien les scientifiques n'ont pas
nous dire exactement faire cela et où
cela est logique et très ambigu entre la
géo ingénierie et l'innovation et verte
ou la décroissance il ya toutes les
options qui sont encore sur la table ça
c'est un arbitrage démocratique pour les
défis qui restent à inventer il ya
quelque chose qui me frappe dans ce que
vous dites 10 goals en diverses et qu'on
a l'impression qu'on n'a pas anticipé
pourtant pardonnez moi et là aussi le
grand public peut se le dire nous avons
des cop nous avons notamment eu la cote
21 est ce que tout cela ne pouvait pas
l'anticiper
sylvie d'ailleurs c'est il ya quelque
chose qui est dit dans dans le nord le
film qui est je trouve très très bien
c'est la comparaison avec le nucléaire
et les déchets nucléaires il est évident
qu'un dès aujourd'hui le gros problème
du nucléaire ce sont les déchets mais le
problème des déchets n'a absolument pas
été examinés en même temps qu'on crée
des centrales nucléaires qu'on
installait des centrales nucléaires on
s'est occupés trente ans après je peux
vous dire même qu' il n'y avait aucune
provision dans les années enfin
exactement 1998 il y avait aucune
provision pour les déchets nucléaires à
l'edf c'est le gouvernement des tno
quelques arabes disent ce n'est plus le
cas c'est plus parce que je vous dis en
98 enfin je dis ça a commencé quand le
nucléaire au moins trente ans avant est
ce qu'on a commis les mêmes erreurs
on a commis exactement on commet les
mêmes erreurs mais il ya quand même une
ou deux choses que je voudrais dire
prenant ce n'est absolument pas vrai de
dire que tous ces pays extrait des
minéraux particuliers pour qu'ils
servent effectivement énergies vertes
uniquement pour en gros les pays riches
la chine par exemple à une politique que
les riches maintenant commencer un petit
riche en passe est un pays riche de plus
en plus quand vous promener en chine
vous rendez compte que c'est quand même
pas complètement un pays riche et la la
la chine a un peu justement une
politique d'utiliser ses propres
matériaux pour faire de l'éolien pour
faire beaucoup de solaire justement
parce qu'elle est la championne de la
fabrication du panneau que c'était donc
ça c'est la première chose
la seconde chose c'est que moi je suis
entièrement d'accord avec ce qui a été
dit sur le problème du modèle en fait
global qu'il faut complètement en
regarder mais ce que ce que je crois
vraiment et je trouve que ce ce que ne
dit pas très bien en fait de film c'est
que il faut phase i c'est à dire que il
ya un problème effectivement de
transition moi je ne pense pas du tout
qu'on arrive avant je ne sais pas
combien de temps et en tout cas beaucoup
plus longtemps que les dates qui sont
exposés aux énergies uniquement que nous
v'la appuiera forcément une part
d'autres énergies il est certain qu'il
fallait éliminer une seule charbon mais
il ya des phases de transition et quand
vous dites par exemple n'y a pas de
problème de temps s'il ya un problème de
temps très très important parce que je
vais dire on a quand même ça c'est de
logique là encore dit mme justement tous
les rapports du giec lui disent depuis
30 ans le dernier thé caoulet plus
alarmant que les oui mais en fait si
vous voulez quelque chose il n'ya pas
grand chose une précision qui finançons
le maire non mais ce qui est nouveau
c'est que les scénarii dia 30 ans du
site du du giec les plus graves de
vienne probable il ya un glissement des
scénarii depuis 30 ans du seul sur le
terrain bon alors effectivement on
aurait pu s'en rendre compte et c'est
vrai qu'on refait la même erreur avec
tous ces matériaux de ton dans le film
part et c'est parce que et ça je crois
qu renan l'a dit on ne se préoccupe pas
d'impact à partir du moment où vous
incorporez dans le prix
l'impact la réparation modal dans un
bouquin ans je crois que j'ai pu 2002
j'avais dit que le hockey au maire tout
le 21e siècle seraient consacrés à
réparer les méfaits des choses très bien
par ailleurs des progrès moi je suis pas
du tout anti progrès de ce qui s'est
passé aux 10,9 et audio parce qu il faut
d innover lors de 10 go alors justement
mais alors
j'ai trouvé le papier dont tout le monde
parle l'appliquent à ce jour extrêmement
intéressant parce que c'est pas
exactement ce que de papier dit il ya un
autre chercheur qui dit je trouve
quelque chose avec lesquels je suis
beaucoup plus d'accord c'est qu'il faut
orienter l'innovation et ça c'est un
problème comme dit ronan de priorité je
veux dire le problème c'est que
aujourd'hui on innove il ya toute une
partie en fait des gens qui enfin
deviennent conscients qu'ils promenade
la décroissance de désespoir
l'apocalypse ou quoi il ya une enquête
sur les jeunes absolument dramatique où
il veut plus de certains veulent plus
faire d'enfants n'a plus d'avenir etc et
il ya une autre partie des des
techniciens des responsables des
responsables politiques qui ne font pas
de hiérarchie dans les financements des
innovations et ça s'est réorientée
l'innovation vers la vie tout simplement
le maintien de la vie sur la planète et
maintien de la vie des humains ça c'est
primordial papiers dont vous parliez je
leur précise pour nos téléspectateurs
c'est la fameuse tribune cosignée par
diego l'endive art qui est avec nous à
distance puisque vous avez déjà évoqué
la question des pistes vous avez lancé
le débat de la d innovation voire de la
décroissance je voudrais qu'on écoute
effectivement cette représentante d'
angie qui elle voit la clé dans
l'évolution technologique écouter
aujourd'hui on n'a pas tout vu dans la
transition énergétique il ya plein de
choses qui vont arriver juste un exemple
les panneaux solaires c'est du solaire
organique c'est très différent du
solaire qu'on voit aujourd'hui des
panneaux solaires qui sont basées sur du
silicium la n'y a pas de composants si
nice yonne c'est comme une feuille de
papier c'est très simple très souple ça
s'installe n'importe où si on pouvait
mettre des feuilles de papier solaire
partout sur les immeubles on aurait une
production qui serait incroyable ronan
dantec voilà une piste d'avenir
finalement je vais peut-être revoir mon
jugement j'ai été dur sur ce
documentaire disons que c'était un peu
n'importe quoi je confirme mais malgré
tout il peut nous servir parce que je
crois que ce que dit ce documentaire
c'est les énergies renouvelables faisons
partie d'un nouveau paradigme d'une
société plus apaisées elles ne peuvent
pas se permettre elle d'être dans
l'ancien modèle notamment sur les
impacts extractives elles peuvent pas
être comme le pétrole le charbon ou
l'uranium
effectivement notre priorité politique à
partir de là ça devrait te dire le
paradigme du développement des énergies
renouvelables dont on a un besoin absolu
je suis totalement d'accord avec bettina
pour dire qu'un certain discours très
décroissant amène à des catastrophes
aujourd'hui en termes de sidération la
société est ce qu'on peut mais on y
arrivera alors vraiment étonnant mais
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de solution
en maintenant des finalement des styles
de vie auquel les gens finalement
tiennent finalement on s'éloigne du
contrat social moi je vous dis et du
coup ça ça ça éloigne du fait de trouver
c'est une majorité politique claire pour
accélérer sur une transition parce qu'on
est dans une course contre la mort moi
je pense que l'histoire de l'espèce
humaine c'est l'innovation de du silex
alan huet on innove tout le temps et ça
n'a aucun sens par rapport à ce qu'est
l'homme de sortir d'une novation par
contre je suis complètement d'accord
avec ce qui a été dit par bt mais tina
je pense que sur le développement massif
dans un système capitaliste classy des
renouvelables aujourd'hui on retrouve
les mêmes errements qu'on a connu pour
d'autres énergies donc il faut essayer
de les réparer rapidement et notamment
ce qui a été dit là est peut-être
finalement documentaire peut permettre
de renforcer là edit et du développement
des énergies renouvelables c'est
peut-être son but caché et dans ce cas
là bravo à ceux qui l'ont fait parce
qu'ils vont permettre d'accélérer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
merci à eux canvel politis et qu'on fait
on voit aussi qu'une partie des
solutions qu'on a sur le climat sont au
fait de main des solutions fondées sur
la nature laisser une nouvelle
production photovoltaïque dont on parle
c'est tout simplement la photosynthèse
et du soleil donc cesser des solutions
très proche de la nature la captation du
co2 c'est un impact biodiversité s'est
régénéré les forêts donc on a aussi des
opportunités en accélérant la transition
d'une société plus apaisée et où
finalement la nature retrouve une place
plus plus important innové en phase avec
la nature en pensant aux impacts marc
francoeur vous faire un petit peu
attention quand on a faim il faut quand
même évité de dire continuellement que
en gros il ne se passe rien ou pas assez
même si on a toujours le sentiment que
ça va pas assez vite mais je dirais que
il ya quand même une prise de conscience
maintenant général le giec nous a dit
récemment quelque chose mais je dis rien
il ya plus de climato sceptiques il ya
plus enfin je veux dire c'est plus la
question deuxièmement cette prise de
conscience se traduit y compris dans les
entreprises
par par des décisions qui vont quand
même dans le bon sens par rapport à des
technologies dont on pense qu'elles
peuvent remplacer les fossiles et toute
façon on n'a pas on a pas trente-six
choix le vent le soleil fera en feront
partie de des sources d'énergie demain
je vais pas encore très bien compris ce
que c'était là des innovations c'est
peut-être un terme décroître limiter nos
usages justement c'est peut-être un
terme pour ne pas dire décroissance mais
à la fin quand même ça de ça ça mais un
vin ça dit qu' il faut pas faire des
innovations pas trop où une innovation
un peu particulière dont je ne sais pas
ce que c'est l armée mais parce que je
pour le moment personnellement je ne
vois pas d'autre chose que la recherche
aussi bien plus d'argent d'un mental la
technologie est plus d'argent dans la
recherche parce que là on n'est pas très
bon aussi bien au niveau public au
niveau privé technologique industrielle
de l'innovation
aujourd'hui on parlerait pas de solaire
et d'éolien si
des chercheurs des ingénieurs n'avaient
pas découvert
l'effet photoélectrique n'avaient pas
découvert le lithium pour les batteries
qui ont donné d'ailleurs un prix nobel
il ya quelques années ou découvrir et c
est ce que je parlais sur le ce que je
disais sur le recyclage et la
récupération c'est aussi des nouvelles
technologies qu'il faudra qu'on mettre
en place donc si ce que je vois beaucoup
c'est quand même une sorte de réponse
par la décroissance qui a qui est un
discours assez technophobes en
présentant la science et la technologie
comme plus des sources de problèmes que
que des sources de et que certains sont
autorisés à le penser comme ça et
effectivement la technologie a conduit
parfois à des difficultés mais moi je ne
vois pas d'autre que l'homme et la femme
bien sûr
sur la terre à pouvoir gagner un dernier
point quand même plus parce que quand on
parle de décroissance
franchement on parle de nos pays qui est
effectivement
gaspille etc mais c'est un problème de
riche ça il faut savoir que sur les 8
milliards d'habitants il y en a plus
d'un an et demi clic
donc effectivement on peut nous de notre
côté être très vigilants sur nos
gaspillages et sur nos efforts mais mais
quand même la plaie ces gens là ont
besoin de croissance ils ont besoin de
ménage parce que diego l'endive avons
envie de vous répondre parler de
décroissance c'est un vocabulaire de
pays riches zygoland ivars
banon je pense je pense que il ya
plusieurs choses qui vont pas dans le
bon débat comme il est mené tout de
suite c'est qu'il ya une sorte de
propension à naturaliser universaliser
l'innovation ça a été dit ça c'est un
argument très très fort contre qui on
tour l'innovation en dix ans les peuples
de la terre en fête ont innové technique
techniquement technologiquement que de
tout temps c'est un peu le propre de la
nature humaine dit n'aurait alors que
quand justement quand tu fais une
anthropologie de l'innovation qui est
aussi une discipline de recherches et
des enquêtes tu te rends compte que non
le propre des sociétés humaines n'est
pas foncièrement d'être dans
l'innovation dans la course à
l'innovation technologique techniques
etc la deuxième chose c'est que ne pas
parler en fait je pense que c'est pas à
nous de dire les béninois les boliviens
n'ont pas le droit de penser la
décroissance gauche où les essentialiser
en dix ans les boliviens ne se pose pas
ce genre de questions parce qu'ils sont
tous en train de crever de faim on fait
de la vérité c'est que non il ya des il
ya des gens qui vivent au quotidien avec
des régimes de subsistance et
d'autonomie qui vont très qui sont très
complexes et qui ont été justement là
aussi mis en évidence par les chercheurs
en 100 mille habitants de plus chaque
année à lagos pour arrêter trois cent
mille habitants de plus chaque année à
lagos ils sont pas dans le système
d'autosubsistance c'est ça la réalité de
la france je suis en train d'animer un
sommet mondial sommet africain sur le
climat avec des intervenants de toute
l'afrique des ong des élus locaux ce que
vous dites là ça n'est pas l'afrique ça
n'est pas l'afrique n'est que lundi
l'armée comme l'afrique c'est pas juste
un pays de start-up heures en puissance
donc il ya aussi il ya aussi un peu de
de calme avec ça et je pense voilà la
question de la décroissance une caisse
un concept moi qui ne convient pas parce
que c'est un concept de maquereaux assez
théorique mais concrètement dans un
territoire quand ya un problème de
l'adaptation des équipements par exemple
sportif les piscines municipales
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des me signifie pas
qu'ils sont les entités les plus
énergivores les plus incompatibles dans
tous les territoires n'a enquêté toutes
les piscines écologiques nouvelles ont
décuplé les usages et font augmenter la
facture énergétique alors qu'elles sont
mises à prix 100 termes d'efficience
énergétique etc donc il ya bien un
problème de choix de ce que l'on fait de
ces équipements est donc soyons concrets
dans dans ces dossiers très pragmatique
et moi ce que je je je là je suis
surpris c'est pourquoi en fait toujours
s'en remettre uniquement à l'innovation
technologique alors qu'il ya aussi toute
une science à travailler un art de
l'arbitrage d'une nouvelle science
démocratique politique où on invente des
institutions qui serait capable de
mettre sur la autour de la table des
citoyens et décidé qu est-ce qui est
essentielle qu'est ce qui est
aujourd'hui de l'ordre du privilège pur
écologique par exemple climatique et à
partir de là faire des arbitrages et
ensuite le mix énergétique suivra mais
la question principale c'est pas taux de
nucléaire ou le bon taux d'énergie
renouvelable la question est aujourd'hui
ce que l'on maintient est ce que l'on
doit
arrêter en finale ce qui de
l'avis ce que je crois c'est vrai dans
ce débat c'est que aussitôt qu'on
prononce le mot décroissance
d'abord il ya de la passion et d'autre
part on oublie la rationalité des choses
ce qu'il y assez qu' on ne fera moi je
suis absolument pôle innovation je crois
comme vous que l'homme se caractérise
par l'innovation là où monsieur qui
vient de parler a raison c'est que
toutes les sociétés effectivement ne
sont pas comme ça tout toute l'histoire
des sociétés ne n'ont pas été mû par par
l'innovation nous notre société
occidentale et franchement d'accord
m'amuser mais le modèle à l'as vécu et
elle va vivre encore par l'innovation
simplement il faut diriger ces
innovations sage déjà dit mais on ne va
pas pouvoir
esquisser le débat sur les limites et je
trouve que le débat sur les limites
étaient beaucoup plus intéressant que le
débat sur la décroissance les limites
c'est des limites en matière de
démographie je dis ça on n'en parle pas
mais c'est quand même très important des
limites c'est aussi qu' on ne peut pas
surexploiter les ressources de la terre
en particulier
réfléchissez ce qui se passe au brésil
les ressources forestières qui ça c'est
absolument catastrophique et ça on l'a
complètement on ne l'a pas vu en fait
pendant deux siècles mais alors les
travailleurs les arts aubry y était mais
bien sûr ça veut dire dans un
remboursement bien sûr ça m'énerve
d'ailleurs il ya toute une école de
l'innovation qui s'appelle l'innovation
sobre l'innovation frugal exactement
c'est ça le terme technique qui est très
important mais ce que je pense c'est
qu'on ne peut absolument pas dire on va
s'en tirer par l'innovation ou bien on
va s'en tirer par la décroissance on va
la société tellement complexes et les
sociétés sont tellement complexes qui va
falloir faire non pas un mix énergétique
mais un mix sociétale et on s'arrêtera
sur ces pistes merci merci infiniment à
tous les quatre d'avoir participé à
cette émission quelques conseils lecture
avec vos livres notamment
halte au catastrophisme les vérités de
la transition énergétique que vous avez
écrit marc fond de cave héritage et
fermeture une écologie du démantèlement
votre ouvrage diego l'endive art avec
emmanuel bonnet et alexandre monein et
enfin l'âge des low tech vers une
civilisation techniquement soutenable de
philippe bihouix je vous ai tout dit fin
de cette émission on se retrouve très
bientôt sur public sénat très vite
[Musique]